how did making your first feature film
and then getting feedback on that film
impacts how you write things now Oh
hugely
I mean omasum way I mean because I mean
we'll make a dresser I mean I you know
I'm gonna be very very honest I was not
focusing that much on screenplay on
narrative on pedestrian plotting on
character development I was very very
much more focused on cold exercise in
style and like that's like very much
making scene after scene of stuff that I
love and trying to like have a thin
story like stitch together with like
duct tape and like that's like that was
100% the intention for that movie but
then like I mean I I thinking like we
were getting like a lot of like feedback
like and the editing of it and you know
I knew that you know there were some
irreparable problems in the movie that
work dictated by like the weakness of
the screenplay and you know coming you
know shot myself in the foot a little
bit but rushing into it a little bit and
and because you know people were just so
they were just taking the movie so
seriously and like they were just like
being so like film-school analytical
about so many things like you know
because the movies like you know it's
it's a I mean if there is a story you
know like the kind of story it is it's a
movie that kind of like it's one of
those kind of movies where it starts off
one thing and then buddy and it's a very
much different thing it's like keeps on
transforming itself it's sort of like
it's like hybrid genre mashup kind of
story
which is definitely movie I want to make
up a time and and I still think it's a
fun picture when I watch it fun movie um
make sure I said like I'm in the 40s
when I just said them I mean like but
but yeah I mean like I have a lake with
monster party I mean like you know that
was like that was a really wonderful
experience because like now I have like
you know there's a much more pressure on
that movie I had a lot of producers
involved a lot of like great people
involve a lot of people that are much
more experienced than I am people that
are extremely brutally honest from the
word go from the writing stage all the
way through to the filming of it's about
editing of it and to the sounds the
music everything I'd like people you
know watching every element of that
movie and they're all like you know very
strong collaborators and I really like
and I really loved working with these
guys and like that I think that was
great it's like III think like what your
trial I want
like I think an idiot maybe I'd like
that that's what I like I think that was
like I was always wanting like there was
like heavy hitting cutthroat producers
they were just say like Chris this is
not working like we have to you know we
have to like you know fix this because
you're gonna kill you shoot yourself in
the foot later on you know the editing
so and I had a lot of that most part
like you know I a lot of people like you
know could you get so inside the movie
and and and you need those outside
perspectives and yeah I don't really
have much of that on Drifter you know I
don't really had you know because we
were kind of all friends with each other
and kind of all kind of came up together
so you know they weren't being as harsh
as they might have should should have
been and but most party you know though
that was not the case you know and so
I'm like but I think you know the thing
that was great in the long run because
at the end a it's the movies it's not
your auteur personality it's not it's
not like you know you're you know a cool
style I mean it's the movie I mean at a
certain point it's not even your movie
anymore it's like that you know has to
be as accessible as possible and I think
and so that must party really was a
great transition for me to it was almost
like a new chapter in my life so it's a
really kind of like explore new
territory and really um you know go back
to like I just the roots of like the
storytelling that I was attracted to and
and and just really approach it from a
much more mature angle and and you know
kind of have to soundtrack and the style
sort of like organically climb inside
the movie a little bit more and not sort
of hijack the movie like drifter was
doing and but yeah I know I mean like I
mean I'm yeah I'm but I'm very proud of
the experience a monster I'm very proud
of the movie yeah do you think most of
the characters that you say your main
character in in any one of your features
do they really go through like the
hero's journey as it's in some ways it's
different horror movies not going to end
necessarily in a great light where yes
this hero has realized our potential or
save something and it's it's often not
the case yeah I mean like I mean drifter
I was like trying to do that but blame a
story definitely I would say as a hero's
journey story
I mean like I I do but I am very
attracted to like stories that are
populated by I like like more ow details
I like movies that have like a moral
tightrope that cared that like the
characters are walking the alley
character might do something that you
might not totally agree with there might
be a little messed up but um and I'm
gonna challenge you if you still want to
keep going on that ride with them I mean
like a movie that I mean a really random
example that I bring up because it's so
notorious for being me so bad it's good
even though I think it's a genuinely
really fun movie as showgirls you know
which I love showgirls it's great like
I'm not saying that ironically I really
enjoy that the first time I saw wasn't
my mother it was a very weird experience
but but I mean like what's really
fascinating about that movie that I'm
trying to do and certainly try to do a
must party a lot was um every character
in a movie is kind of like a little like
you know kind of like has badness in
them like I mean they might disguise but
they're all kind of like very they have
bad bad qualities about them even like
now know me like the main character and
there's like the only innocent character
in that movie is like the girls like the
makeup artist and she gets punished for
being innocent in this world of horrible
people
and she gets punished quite horribly and
people forget about that really horrible
scene I'm a third act with her and the
rock star guy and like that's a very
eye-opening vicious scene that she gets
punished for being good at being a good
pure person around these terrible people
including the lead character and like
that's that's sort of like what I try to
dabble in with mouth supporting like
that where it's like because you know
it's sort of like very flawed people
again it's even more flawed people and
the people that you would think would
not be flawed or way more flawed than
you could've possibly imagined and but
there are a couple there are innocent
people in the movie that that get
extremely punished for being very
genuine and and like that's like that's
the kind of I mean that that's always
been sir I don't I I mean it sounds like
a sick way of looking at things but
that's always been sort of like the
that's always been sort of like the the
outlook that I've always liked
all the world and you know like we're
you know just sometimes like good deeds
go
you know like later so like no good deed
goes unpunished or whatever in light and
and just innocent people paying the
price for being what they are and bad
people serve having this power and like
you know just the moral corruption of of
the world and like in our society and
our generation and I'm and I'm always
like trying to make some sort of like
bold statement about how I see that I'm
not just trying to make these sort of
like cool genre movies and violence and
cool stuff my um I mean that's all fun
but it's like I am really trying to like
sneak in like a very bold statement
about how I see the world because a lot
of it's very personal I mean like it's
wacked out as some of them some of the
stuff is it is very very personal about
like the kind of tone and the kind of
the nature of certain main characters
we're supposed to be rooting for like
sort of like I mean every one of them
sort of had I mean I think like when
you're making movies I think you when
you're writing stories I think you
really have to you have to put all your
good traits on screen but you also have
to put a lot of your bad traits on
screen and no one wants to see just good
traits me you have to almost embarrass
yourself by putting in really bad traits
about yourself and and and and that's
just like I mean do it in like a very
fun kind of accessible way but like um
but yeah I mean I that's like that's
that's always been a sort of like kind
of those kind of stories I've always
been really attracted to or like Carrie
yeah I mean like Carrie's grave right
just being punished at home being
punished I mean that's such a cynical
story and then she yeah and then just it
has no it has no she has no other
options but to like just terrorize her
prom and then she pays the price for it
like I mean that's such like a sad
what's that's a great morality tale and
I mean I don't know there's the kind of
stories that I just think like you know
because everyone has flaws I'm like and
I and everyone has like darkness inside
of them and some people do a better job
clothing like disguise in them but but I
just I just I like movies it's really
kind of like push the band
like what are like like protagonists are
capable of and um sort of like I don't
know maybe somewhat bad people against
worse people or something you know
that's I just always been I just always
been attractive that kind of
storytelling you know right and when you
see the bad people are the ones that are
sort of the stereotypical what you think
that if you saw them in a dark alley and
sometimes those are we aren't the ones
that are the worst yeah it's the ones
that you would think are a little more
trustworthy oh yeah I mean I mean like I
you know like well my favorite directors
is Larry Clark and like you know how he
films like bully and kids and Ken Park
and all that and like those films are
really very disturbing experiences but
like they are characters that are I mean
like I very much around those kind of
people like my brother was very much
like he he's very much friends with
those kind of kids so I I just like I
think a lot of that kind of stuff like
hearing really revolting things that
these kids would say and seeing stuff
that they would do and hearing stories
about them what they would do and and I
think a lot of that stuff like III try
to translate in sort of like a you know
I guess cinematic format and try to go
back to that kind of that's just like no
that's just the way it just comes from
like up you know just growing up and the
kind just the kind of people I was
around in high school and all that just
the kind of things that I saw and you
know just the yeah I mean like I I just
and just just really you know disturbing
tragic things that are happening with
people and that was always um I mean I
just you know it's at a certain point
you can't quite see the world in any
other way and so until you get into like
you were later years but like but I I'm
just like I'm just like very stemming on
like how I how the world was around me
growing up like the kind of people that
I interacted with or the kind of people
that I grew up around and they're good
people's houses that I went to and just
the stuff I saw and like all these like
really whacked out like dysfunctional
things that were happening inside these
houses and these kids and
and so yeah I mean like I'm just that
that's like I'm just very me I'm very a
track I'm just a very attractive that
that kind of that kind of stuff and I
just really making it as grounded as
possible but you know in like a
cinematic cinematic kind of way
you